wir machen heute einen käsekuchen und
zwar einen der extrem schnell geht wenn
ihr keine zeit haben und auch nicht wie
die zutaten dann macht dieses rezept
unbedingt nach ist so ein richtiger
klassiker gab früher immer meinen eltern
und auch bei mir wenn ich einfach
richtig bock hat auf und käsekuchen aber
die zeit gedrängt hat also kummer mit
[Musik]
für dieses rezept könnt ihr entweder
einfach nur euren schneebesen nehmen
oder in dem schnell dass handrührgerät
ganz sehen möchtet ihr braucht auf jeden
fall eine große schüssel und ein paar
standard zutaten die ich euch ganz genau
hier unten in die video beschreibung
schreibe oder beziehungsweise infobox
ich sagte auch immer anders auf jeden
fall starte ich jetzt mit meinem quark
das wird ein ganz klassischer quark hier
so kuchen und ich hab hier einmal kinder
stoffe und einmal krank mit 20 prozent
fett ich möchte immer gern ich mache mal
50 50 manchmal nämlich auch statt 20
prozent in 40 prozentigen aber ihr
dürftet auch das komplette kilo in
magerquark nehmen dass es gar kein
problem ich immer einfach das was gerade
da ist und ich starte jetzt damit indem
ich das in die schüssel gebe da gebe ich
schon zucker mit rein und natürlich ganz
viel ein extrakt
[Musik]
bei mir darf neben der vanille auch
zitrone nicht fehlen und dann nehmt euch
jetzt am besten mit bio zitrone die sind
ungespritzt und da darf man auch die
schale verwenden und die gibt noch mal
einen richtig guten geschmack bevor ich
jetzt reiben nämlich die zitrone und
reinheit
rollvi auf der arbeit flächen hin und
her dann tritt immer ein bisschen mehr
saft aus und man hat einfach mehr davon
und jetzt ist es ganz wichtig beim
reiben ich nehme diese feinen reibe dass
ihr wirklich nur die gelbe schale reibt
und unten drunter seht ihr dann kommt
auch schon was weiß und dieses weiße ist
super bitter und dann müsst ihr opfer
von dass wir das nicht rein weil sonst
wo natürlich nach dem backen warum euer
käsekuchen leicht bitter schmeckt so
nachdem ich das erledigt habe gebe ich
gleich auch noch einen keinen spritzer
vom saft mit dazu
[Musik]
die eier sind drin jetzt fehlt noch
sahne da brauche ich aber nicht die
ganze packung ich finde es aber ganz
cool vag ausland haben ja den mit dem
drehverschluss und ich verbrauche ja
sehr viel sahne weil ich sehr viel backe
es gebe ich 400 gramm rhein kann es
mittlerweile ganz gut abschätzen und 100
gramm bewahre ich mir auf und da mache
ich mir dann heute mittag einfach ein
nudelgericht dann packe ich doch noch
mit der zucht so und jetzt fange ich an
hier alles mit dem handwerk mal langsam
zu verrühren ihr müsst es auch wirklich
nur so lange rühren wie es notwendig ist
das heißt solange bis sich alles
verbindet und ganz zum schluss habe ich
ja noch mehl und backpulver und das
werde ich dann dazu sieben und auch noch
mal kurz unterrühren
[Musik]
der käse kuchenteig ist jetzt fertig hat
echt keine fünf minuten gedauert und
jetzt nehme ich mir eine springform
einer hat einen durchmesser von 24
zentimetern und eigentlich könnte ihnen
jetzt so einfüllen oder wenn ihr mögt
dem boden mit backpapier aus klein ich
mache es anders ich hätte das und zwar
das in folgenden grund nicht damit man
das später in besser lösen kam sondern
weil mutter einfach noch mal schön
geschmack gibt daher hätte ich den boden
und die seiten vollständig und hatten
bei jedem stück das man probiert noch
mal so ein richtig schön beträgen
geschmack und ihr wisst ja auch butter
ist als geschmacksträger deswegen darf
das damit nie fehlen und anschließend
werde ich den teig einfach einfüllen und
euch die back verraten
[Musik]
den teig muss jetzt nicht extra
verstreichen ihr könnt einfach hin und
her rücken und dann ist er automatisch
klappt ich hab den backofen vorgeheizt
auf 180 grad ober und unterhitze und
jetzt ist es wichtig dass ihr wirklich
nach der hälfte der backzeit also nach
etwa 30 minuten den käsekuchen
rausnehmen den zehn minuten abkühlen
lässt und dann weitere 25 minuten buck
das heißt die gesamte bauzeit beträgt 55
bis maximal 60 minuten und warum holen
wir den nach der hälfte raus das bewegt
einfach dass wir dann kein riss haben
was er mir aber oft passiert ich habe
eine offene küche hier ist alles offen
und grad bei durchzug passiert es halt
oft dass so ein käsekuchen dann auch
später nach der backzeit trotzdem reist
was ich persönlich aber nicht so schlimm
finde aber ihr könnt zumindest vermeiden
dass in riss bekommen beziehungsweise
dass der riss so unendlich groß ist so
ich geh jetzt mal in den backofen und
dann zeige ich euch nachher wie ich
denke nicht noch mal raus holen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe jetzt aus einem direkt zwei
gemacht also den habe ich gestern abend
schon gebacken und den grad haltung
videos 12 das gleiche rezept das einzige
was sich verändert habe bzw was ich hier
anders gemacht habe ist dass ich hier
gerade noch mal mit dem messer während
ich es zehn minuten abkühlen lassen
einmal am rand eingeschnitzt habe das
bewegt einfach dass es dann nicht in der
mitte reißt sondern entlang der linien
und ich weiß nicht ob ich das jetzt
schöner finde hier habe ich gestern auch
alles nach annahme gemacht und hier ist
ganz kleiner feiner riss gekommen aber
normalerweise habe ich immer so ein
ozonloch da drin also so ist es für mich
perfekt ich selber stelle mich halt auch
gar nicht an rissen aber hört euch
einfach nur mal zwei varianten zeigen
und das ganze muss halt nach dem kühlen
ganz ganz wichtig nach dem backen
auskühlen so meine ich das also
mindestens vier stunden noch besser über
nacht service mit dem gemacht und den
will ich gleich auch verkosten mit dem
hammer
[Musik]
das ist ein klassischer käsekuchen ja
und somit willkommen beim test als so
richtig gut also das ist wirklich einer
der klassischen
klassischen night klassischen
plastisches 9 klassischen eines der
cafés sitzen käsekuchen er war ich weiß
keine thorsten beschrieben zwischen
schillerplatz gut wir nehmen nichts an
sebastian schiek in den mund so ich
würde mal sagen kann was kurz kurz
erheben möchte sie sich die bälle
pünktchen hier ich bin
das war einfach mein leben in zwei
sekunden cesar und cremig und frisch
aber nicht so cremig welt des
tanztheaters denn schließlich will ihn
letztlich in den schatten stellen der
ist auch mega neckar und gemüse sonst
erschieße keinen cheesecake das wirklich
das meer nach wendel ja aber das ist so
richtig passt die skate so ist es frisch
schmecken ist so richtigen so ein
cheeseburger war sind noch käsekuchen
schmücken der schmeckt vorlag ich finds
richtig lecker leute macht und auch so
wenn ihr euch das video gefallen hat
dann durch meinen live button bleibt
voll geworden muss ich sagen like an
kommentiert und auch weitere ja okay da
manchmal sagen bis zum nächsten mal auf
die skizzen
[Musik]